slamming into Florida
hurricane Ian hit the state's West Coast
with Winds of over 240 kilometers per
hour so this is a devastating storm for
parts of Florida not just on the
Southwest coast but also Inland
associated with some of these impacts
this is going to be a storm we talk
about for many years to come
it's one of the most powerful storms
ever recorded in the U.S
the authorities have warned the pounding
rain and wind will continue as the
hurricane crosses Florida to the
Atlantic Ocean
the state's Governor says that it could
take years to recover from the
devastation left behind
there's a
major major event it's going to be going
to be a tragic event in many ways and we
understand this is not just a 48-hour
ordeal this is going to be something
that is going to be there for days and
weeks and months and unfortunately in
some circumstances even years the flood
waters as well as winds are causing the
most damage
the hurricane has knocked out
electricity to more than one million
homes and businesses
in the city of Tampa the power of the
storm sucked the water right out of the
Bay
even though the hurricane weakened as it
moved Inland authorities are warning of
devastating rain wind and even tornadoes
still to come as it tears across the
state
let's get a closer look at this with
Matthew capucci a meteorologist with the
My Radar app is in Port Charlotte
Florida Matthew what more can you tell
us about the situation in Florida right
now
hey good morning you know I can say
personally I've never witnessed a storm
at least firsthand this intense so we're
saying right now conditions are
beginning to die down here where we are
which is good to finally have a break
from the wind and the rain and
everything else the first half of the
storm was bad especially for areas of
south support Charlotte we're talking a
Naples we're talking Fort Myers for
southern highest storm surge ever
recorded at more than two two and a half
meters was completely inundated the
coastline where I was we saw significant
winds in the order of I'd say 140 plus
kilometers per hour and plentiful
rainfall then we got the eye ordinarily
the second half of the storm was weaker
in this case it was far stronger from a
wind standpoint we saw winds gusting
close to gosh 170 to 190 kilometers per
hour we saw a absolutely plentiful
rainfall to the point where even Beyond
storm surge every place that we were
trying to drive through or around was
inaccessible due to extreme flooding
with rainfall rates of five plus to fix
perhaps centimeters per hour it's an
extremely difficult situation and now
you know this is the first time in my
life I've looked out the window and
can't find a single light anywhere the
only lights we've seen all night long
were actually hunkered down in a garage
right now are from Transformers blowing
so power flashes why was the second part
of the storm so much stronger
you know that's something that I think
we're going to
time because honestly it didn't really
follow the the textbook structure of a
typical storm we had expected this storm
several days ago to be an Awakening
Trend towards landfall Instead This
defined all laws rapidly intensifying
this morning to a borderline category
five and so many things really surprised
us about this so what's the damage like
the damage from what I can see is that
of a miles wide ef2 ef3 tornado you'll
have a lot of people whose homes are
underwater or roofs that are missing
you'll have my goodness I mean the
building we're underneath right now had
its roof peeled back lots of areas are
still underwater further Inland from
fresh water flooding it's just one thing
after another and I think until daylight
comes in about three or four hours we
won't really understand the scope of the
devastation
Matthew capucci meteorologist with the
My Radar app in Port Charlotte Florida
thank you
thank you
let's pick up on some of those points
with Ajit niranjan from DW environment
as we heard there not a textbook storm
that we're seeing there what what's
different exactly what are we seeing
here
so I mean this was one of the strongest
storms in U.S recorded history but it's
definitely not going to be one of the
strongest storms in the US's future I
mean these sorts of events are becoming
stronger because of climate change
they're not becoming more frequent I
mean hurricanes generally but these kind
of category three to four to five storms
definitely are and so this is the kind
of projection that climate scientists
are saying we've got all sorts of new
factors that were brought in by burning
fossil fuels and heating up the planet
like sea levels that have risen higher
there's more warmer air can hold more
water vapor in it so when it does rain
it rains much harder
and on top of that you have all sorts of
other factors that are maybe a bit more
difficult to plot out but one thing that
we're seeing often is storms that are
starting to just slow down and this
looks like what's happening here that's
slowing down which means there's more
time in which the rain can just be
inundated flooding onto an area that's
already inundated
um how then can places like Florida
which already have problems with
flooding uh keep up with with this sort
of extreme weather and these sorts of
events
so the unfortunate truth is that there
are limits to how much communities and
people in regions can adapt to these
sorts of events that are getting
stronger
there is a huge amount they can do
before they get to the point where
places are actually unlivable and so to
actually reduce the damage and the death
toll and the amount of infrastructure
that gets destroyed there's all sorts of
things they can do so having good
evacuation plans warning people early
and making sure that people respond in
an effective way clear communication
from politicians all of that will reduce
death tolls and make people able to
actually cope with the events much more
but you still have the problems of homes
that will be washed away people have to
pay more for their insurance premiums to
be able I mean some people won't even be
able to insure their homes anymore
um so what's this all mean what do
governments have to do because from what
you're saying it it may not be more
frequent events but but even some more
severe events is that what you're saying
exactly and so I mean there's two very
clear things governments can do I mean
first world leaders who promised to hold
global warming at 1.5 degrees Celsius
above pre-industrial temperatures they
can honor that pledge they can put in
the policies in place to actually get
there at the minute we're almost looking
to double that temperature Target and
that means stronger storms stronger
hurricanes on the other hand right now
they need to accept that we've already
heated the planet about 1.1 degrees
Celsius and that means that the world is
hotter the world is different to how it
used to be a hundred years ago and that
means they need to put in place the
adaptation measures to actually allow
people like we just said to evacuate in
the face of danger to have the support
they need when they do lose their homes
and to have plans in place so that
people don't end up suffering unusely
but is it that simple to just decide
okay we're going to hold the temperature
at this certain level it's definitely
not simple but the reassuring user that
the technology is almost completely
there and it's cheap there's so many
things that governments could be doing
that would hold warming far lower than
what they expect it to do
if it does end up going over the limits
that kind of they've agreed on there are
ways to suck carbon dioxide back out of
the atmosphere but these are less tested
less proven so what scientists keep
stressing is cut emissions now and
faster and you save a whole lot of
suffering for the rest of the century
thank you very much for coming in from
DW environment